[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zema and on
bachelor in paradise the love triangle
of dean danielle and christina finally
came to an end
i'm going to tell christina that i
want to pursue whatever
with you dean pledged his allegiance to
danielle
as it sounds to like pursue
dilo christina was upset but after
getting some good advice from friends
why are you fighting for someone who's
not fighting for you
she chose to give her rose to no one
i wanted to be valued i want to be
respected and
i want to
be put first
dean and christina shared a tearful
goodbye
and we actually know they've hung out
since filming ended
so what do you guys think are christina
and dean back together now should they
be or should dean be the bachelor he's
been a much talked about front runner
but his time in paradise has been
fraught with drama and monday night he
said this
i just think that i'm not necessarily
ready for like that serious of a
relationship right now let me know what
you think over on twitter
[Music]